May I took came and the kids, we
traveled around Australia or in, uh,
it must've been the end of 2007 early
last year and we camped out on the tunnel
me desert,
which is like one of the last places
to really be discovered and explored in
Australia. Like there's, there's no
artificial lights out there at all,
like whatsoever.
And we camped out on the desert.
90 thing that was around us
was like dingoes and camels.
Like you'd hear them moving for
the night. Camels. Yeah. Yeah.
But we sat there at camp. I just
had the, my, my truck, my ute,
you know,
with the camper on the back,
like real lightweight
set up and we sat there,
no lights on in the camper or anything.
So you're sitting in the pitch black
moonless night and the media's dude like,
I reckon we counted 40,
50 media's over like half hour or an hour,
just the naked.
I seen him,
perfect dude sitting there with
the family and I'm like, this is,
this is the best. Like this is, it
was so amazing just to sit there,
especially with the kids.
And Kim as well.
Nerving when you find out how many times
they enter the atmosphere? Oh yeah,
there's a, I think good Jaimee
could probably look this up,
but I think a hundred tons of media
hits the Earth every single day.
100 tons, dude. But most of it enters
in dust form because it breaks up.
But uh, so last year, um,
I was up at my cabin just chilling
out by myself. Woke up in the morning,
they to do a pierce,
walked out and I'm looking up and this
media come through and it was so bright
that it actually lit up the ground dude,
like the most incredible
media that I've seen.
I had a time lapse photo going
in the opposite direction.
I quickly turned that around and you
see that the media's dust for like,
it lasts for 25 minutes, half
an hour in the, in the camera,
and it's just drift and change and
shape in the atmosphere. It was insane.
So it's just like every now and
then there's like a real good one.
So then I started looking it
up and I seen one that Rick,
a whole village like in
Germany or something like that.
This asteroid comes through rec
and shit that it didn't even touch,
but that comes so close to it.
It blows the walls and the windows
out and everything, and I'm like,
this is fucking scary.
We live on a little speck that's
turning in one of many galaxy. You know,
my friend Randall Carlson put it best.
He said,
we live in the middle of a
shooting gallery, isn't it?
In signs, just the time.
The perspective of, you know,
hundreds of millions of years.
It doesn't seem,
it doesn't register to us because we're
only around for a hundred years. Yeah.
So when we look up and we see the moon,
I mean the moon looks like a fucking
stop sign in the most Janky is redneck
town. When people shoot at signs, yes, the
wound looks like it's just fucking shot.
It's just getting nailed all the time,
especially with no atmosphere.
All those things make
it all the way through.
Nothing gets slowed down by the
air or burns up in the atmosphere.
Isn't that crazy? Everything just slams
into it. Boom, boom. Magic being up there.
It must be all day long. I must be
slamming things. Oh, it was only a,
I think it was like 10,000 years
ago. There was like a big bang, like,
like a big media hit
hit the earth. And, uh,
I started looking into that and then I
started really looking into aborigines in
Australia, indigenous, how long they'd
been around for and stuff like that.
And there's now evidence to say that
they'd been around for 70,000 years.
They live through like three of those
big media is hitting the earth. You know,
like, it's crazy to think about like why,
I wish we had video cameras back then,
you know, and I could have recorded
that. We could look at it now.
Like imagine that. Well, Randall Carlson,
the guy that I talked about earlier,
he is a proponent of this theory
that this is what ended the ice age.
Yeah.
And he's got some pretty compelling
evidence to back it up in terms of,
um,
like massive,
massive fields field with a dead woolly
mammoths and died almost instantly.
Some of them with their legs broken from
the force of the impact on real. Yeah.
He's, you know, it's really
interesting because he's a guy who, uh,
I don't think he has a
degree in this stuff,
but he's so well read in it that he has
these debates and conversations with
people that do have these degrees in it
and he can tell them things about it.
And it's hard in those fields to be taken
seriously if you don't have a phd in
whatever discipline it
is. But man, his, uh,
his work on these things is so compelling
and the podcast that I did with them
are just mind blowing.
But in,
in terms of like the evidence that points
to some event that ended the ice age
very rapidly and caused the
disintegration of the poet, of the, um,
the ice that was over North
America, you know, North America,
it's something like a mile high
plus she device over the most of it.
Just 10,000 years ago. Yeah.
Yeah. 12,000 years old,
I think I was driving through Wyoming
and they've got all these signs up in
Wyoming that are really interesting.
And it was desert rock formation.
It'll tell you how all of that rock
formation is, how it formed. You know,
cause like, you know, rock usually
in beds, in layers like this,
it's formed in layers like this. And then
you'll see a rock like that, you know,
all the lines of like this,
there's some of them there that are like
hundreds of million years old, you know,
and there's a sign there Sean.
And it's just,
it's incredible to think
how much the irfs changed.
And you just said it were around for a
hundred years at a time Max. You know?
And it's just like we're
dropping the freaking ocean.
Like even the whole human ratios that
is a drop in the ocean compared to like
how old the earth is.
And it's just crazy to think of like,
it's hard to comprehend that there
was that much high. So over here,
cause there's none now, you know, but
it's been that long, you know, and that's,
yeah,
it's mind boggling to think of.
Well they say they find shells in Montana.
I found some on top of friggin some
big Macer out in the desert. Dude,
there's no water for miles
and there's shells. There's,
there was like staff fish fossilized
the rocks and it's all like coral bed,
you know. And that was like, that
was like the bottom of the ocean.
That was a reef bed as the
Great Western inland sea. Yeah.
They had sharks out there.
I'd say. I think they had
megla dawns and Montana Shit.
They find dinosaurs there all the
time. Want to Dudley's friends? Well,
Dudley knows a guy who has a ranch out
there in Montana and he found a bone in
his, uh, in his ranch. Just maybe
something protruding from the ground.
Um, and he wanted someone to get a look
at it. So he got ahold of some, uh,
I guess, what would you have
paleontologist? They went and they said,
you got to fucking t rex here, Bro. I'll
Lee t rex on your property. Unbelievable.
They, I think they gave him $1
million for it. Really? Yeah.
Cause this is like a fully intact
or close to intact t-rex. Far Out.
Yeah.
They apparently monetary please Colorado
would you got then megalodon was found
supposedly in Texas. Jesus
Christ. What the fuck?
That's a fucking great. What? Shock boy.
That's a stupid movie. The Meg. The Meg.
Yeah. I'll watch that shit. I
watched it the other day. I was like,
what am I sit in through here?
So stupid.
There wasn't just one.
There was a bunch of them did get or
can you find out how much a media,
yeah, I have. I was
struggling to find that.
And then I think I found what you found.
So it says, here's from NASA's website,
there's a hundred tons of dust
and sand size particle every day.
Hit Earth every day. But
that's every day, doesn't it?
It seems like it would put the balance
of the earth off, you know, like,
you know what I mean? Like, are we
sending shit back out and displays that?
We sent in a hundred tons of [inaudible]
out in the spice every day to off load
this.
Look at this 2000 years or so,
a Meteora meteoroid the size of a
football field hits earth and causes
significant damage to the area.
That's fine.
Once every faculty in the next 10 minutes
and object large enough to threaten or
a civilization comes along, not
just that bigger than that, uh,
impact craters on earth,
the moon,
another planetary planetary bodies or
evidence of these occurrences. Yeah.
They don't even know. You know,
that's the most spooky thing.
Like Neil degrasse Tyson said that we
are decades away from being able to do
anything about one of those
things coming our way. And I said,
so all these periods of think that like
they could stop it when it's happening.
He's like, not happening. He goes,
there's nothing you could do.
What about Armageddon, Bro?
The mercy Bruce Willis. Yeah.
We've got a solar swells up there. He'll
figure it out. Sort it out. Yeah. Yeah.
There's a,
people have like a real distorted idea
of the technological capabilities in
terms of like, first of all,
NASA, so under budgeted,
they barely have enough money
to put satellites in orbit.
They don't have enough money
to stop coming in. I mean,
the amount of money you would
need is so fucking massive.
They would take a cooperative joint effort
of every major country in the world.
And it's such a of nature and you know,
a force of nature usually can't be
fucked with scary. Well, they're all,
they can do all they think they
could do in the, and not even now,
but in the future is move it
off target slightly. Yeah. Yeah.
Somehow or another give it a bump,
send it into Mars or something at a
certain distance and it completely misses.
Yeah. Cracks and Nunes dare
darkness a lot for forever.
Yeah.
It's scary spaces scary and you don't
really see space unless you're out there
with no light pollution.
I don't think people that don't
camp or that you don't go, you know,
you look up at night like last night,
uh,
well not last night but a couple of
nights ago when it wasn't raining.
It was a clear night and I saw quite a
few stars because it was no moon and I
was like wow, it's so pretty, but it
ain't shit. But you know what I'm saying.
The volume over. Yeah. It was photos
that you have. Yeah. Add at my farm.
You can just sit there with a knife at
all and you can look right into those.
There's so many stars and it looks like
a dark spot of the Milky Way cause you
can see so much of it.
You know,
you see a color in it and everything
gets an amazing spot. Yeah.
The color's weird. Right. What is the
color? What is that on the, I was,
I looked at some photos of it. Oh, not
my own photo. Someone else's photos.
And that will show on the,
the like the roller images and the color
that was coming out of these raw images.
They look like absolute pillars, like
painted pillars dude. Yeah. You know,
and it's, I dunno, I dunno if it's a depth
finish it. If it's something like that.
Jamie put go to Adam's a
that the first man. Yup.
Instagram again like these,
this is like the ones of um
oh look at that one from BC. Go
Down one strip that, that one there.
That's with the northern
lights in it. Wow. But yeah,
that's sudden no light
pollution out there.
Obviously you saw the northern
lights and Casey, I don't know.
You could see him in BC.
Yup.
That's how you had to be in like
Icelander so I'm sure that was cool.
I've seen him when I was
in northwest territories,
I lining up the ground like and Ryan,
front of your eyes.
I would just like dance and constantly
right in front of your eyes.
That was awesome. In the
Northwest Territories of
Australia? No, in Canada. Oh,
okay. Yeah. Northern
territories of Australia.
Right. That's what they call it.
The last is, yeah. Okay. So
where's it at the best though?
Is it the best place to see it in like
Iceland or some shit or Norway? I Dunno.
I Dunno.
I've seen it.
So I've seen it in northwest
territories is I've seen it in BC.
I don't think we didn't say it in
Alberta when we're there. No, no,
but I think we had shitty
wherever wall will. Yeah,
it's gotta be a crazy thing to see though,
Hon. It's like green smoke in the sky.
Yeah.
If you go down a couple more Jamie please.
Okay.
Silent. There's the, there's
the farm go up one. Yeah,
hit that one in the middle there.
Wow. Look at the car. That one. God,
that's amazing.
And is that what kind of,
you have to do something with
the aperture. Wolf of Stata is,
it's open for longer, so it's Gavin in
more light. You know, like the human eye.
You have to actually lie there and the
dock for a fe wall and just like stare
into that sort of to
get a good look at it.
How long has it opened to get that image?
That's like a 13 or 15 seconds.
Oh Wow.
Yup.
You can leave it in for 30 seconds or
you can put it on like a actual jammed
open for a long time,
but it's way too much light for what
the farm has and you can start getting a
lot of distortion as well.
That's such a cool picture
with the cabin as well.
The light coming out of the cabin.
Isn't that crazy that there
could be infinity irfs out there?
Yeah, that's what's crazy is that
each one of those is a son. Yeah.
And most of them are bigger.
I mean,
apparently our son is a little
bitch ass bitch ass son.
Thank God for that. I was,
there will be fraud. Oh, we
just have to be further away,
but the big ones don't last that long.
Apparently Our signs a good one. It's a,
it's like a,
it's like a Toyota Tercel spot
that gave shade Ohio locks.
You may fucking last cruiser.